Peggy's 16
get that gun away from me psycho hey
leave him alone
max Chloe welcome home max that's Rachel
amber something happened to her
what a difference a day makes my entire
life has been changed in just 24 hours
not to mention the course of my destiny
and Chloe's this must prove that were
meant to be friends forever I want proof
you can rewind time the tracker drops is
much the cop gets an emergency alert on
his radio I pledge allegiance to max and
the power for which she stands I vow to
use my powers for good not evil what's
up Kate I think it's awesome you set a
Tong record on video we're going to be
sorry someday there's something ominous
going on it black well there's a lot of
beauty here but a lot of darkness too
I have to find out what's going on hey
what are you hiding there girlie that's
Rachel's bracelet give it to me right
now [ __ ] please step back
put that down it's time to be in every
day here Oh No
some crazy [ __ ] is going down on the
girls doll listen everybody remain
seated
how can it be such a shitty week and yet
one of the best of my life because we're
back in action again I keep seeing that
tornado
and I wonder where all of this is going
to end
so you can't help me you have to
understand my position should I go to
the police
yeah max I won't forget you
your rewind power has to be connected to
that snow yesterday
since you're the mysterious superhero
I'll be your faithful chauffeur and
companion